when you're talking about goats of the W
I need my name to be up there at least
top three like that's my goal is like I
want something like when you're thinking
of women's basketball when you're
thinking of the W I want my name to be
on come on tell them Asia tell them
takes like whatever it needs to get
there whether it's the Rings whether
it's the accolades individually like I
want to be up there in that category you
on your way being a champion already
only 26. y'all got Firepower now MVP
two-time two times two times she got the
defensive player of the year she's a
gold medalist yeah she's got her own
statue at 26. they do that when you like
50 60. crazy